en la siguiente gráfica es una función
de x bueno recordemos que para que esa
función de x
debemos tener que para cada x que entre
a nuestra cajita de función y igual a fx
y esta cajita
debemos tener solamente una salida o un
valor para cada entrada de x se debe
tener un solo valor de g como resultado
en esta gráfica vemos que el dominio de
aquí solo tiene un valor que es este
menos 2 y si queremos poner este menos 2
este menos 2 como entrada a esta cajita
que no sabemos si es función o no
que vamos a obtener pues pues aquí vemos
que tenemos una infinidad de valores de
ni tanto positivos como negativos
tenemos igual a 4 igual a 5 igual a 1
igual a punto 5 igual a menos 4 menos
5.5 etcétera tenemos una infinidad de
valores de g para este solito valor de x
así que aquí tenemos muchísimos valores
de salida de esta cajita por lo que ya
no es función de x función
no es función